did you hear the news i heard that
critter junction got a fever
and the only prescription is more
services let's take a look at how we
help critter junction turn their
monolith into microservices
while much of critter junction's focus
has been on redesigning existing systems
to be more scalable
they also had to have a plan for new
systems they wanted to add a level
editor feature and instead of using c
plus like the main game engine they
wanted to write it in a designer
friendly scripting language like python
this led them to wonder if it would be a
good idea to break out all of their core
services into independent services
and if so how should they go about it
when our team first took a look at
critter junction's architecture
we told them the truth not everything
needs to be a micro service
micro service apps add complexity
because how the independent services
communicate can be non-obvious and
that communication happens over a
network so message passing and security
can become
a concern plus just by better
architecting your monolith to include
monitoring
logging ci cd and health checks you can
get a lot of the benefits of a micro
service based approach
like observability and recoverability
for their level editor feature
critter junction needed the ability to
deploy services independently and for
separate teams to write components
in different languages so for their
needs a micro service
or service oriented architecture gave
them the most flexibility
we thought this would be pretty
straightforward but we ran into a
problem
while some of their services didn't
require state some of the services
clearly did
and some services were tightly coupled
in a way that made it unclear if they
actually required state or not
ideally you want your services to be
stateless and not retain any local
persistent data
this way each request or interaction can
be handled without needing to know what
happened before
this approach makes it a lot easier to
scale and recover your services because
services can grow
shrink or be restarted without losing
any data
luckily before we started refactoring
the system we took the time to create a
plan
the first step was to take an inventory
of the entire system
we spent some time refactoring the
monolith to couple some of the
components
while this was going on the new level
editor was designed and deployed as a
microservice
this was great because it gave critter
junction a preliminary test for the new
approach
where they could set up and test
deploying services independently and
make sure they could communicate with
each other
then we started migrating the monolith
in stages
instead of doing everything at once we
started with the stateless components
like the ui
after the stateless components we went
on to migrate stateful services with
independent data sets like their off
service
which wasn't as easy finally we migrated
trickier features with shared data sets
that we couldn't quite
fully decouple like their shopping cart
feature
over time critter junction can work to
re-architect these features but for now
they have a functional and more easily
maintainable microservice architecture
[Music]
transitioning from a monolith to
microservice approach isn't always
necessary
and it isn't always effortless but in
this case it gave critter junction key
business features they needed
so it was the right choice so that's a
wrap for this episode of season of scale
stay tuned to learn how critter junction
continues to improve the design of their
app architecture and dev processes
and remember always be architected
[Music]